[Music]
US foreign policy over the last 15 to 25
years hasn't really been working on
delivering the goods on making sure that
America is safe and secure and at the
same time being cognizant of the
economic and human costs of our
engagements the United States had
followed a more realistic approach to
the world that it's not as if Libya or
Iraq would be thriving liberal
democracies it's a foreign policy of
restraint isn't going to create heaven
on earth but neither is a policy of
primacy in fact primacy has often led
the United States to create situations
where there's greater instability more
problems lots of unintended consequences
that have spilled over to other places
and Iraq is a perfect example of that
Isis would not exist in Iraq had it not
been for the United States opening
Pandora's box by our regime change
efforts and that obviously spilled over
to places like Syria you'd also have
some of these problems with our allies
like Turkey related to some of the
issues dealing with the Kurds the
problem is that these war aims expanded
well beyond what was possible and again
really thought through what the ideal
would be without thinking about the
constraints that meant reality would
look a lot different than that ideal it
would be great if Afghanistan were a
liberal democracy thriving economically
and not a place where folks like Al
Qaeda could operate out of the problem
is that that wasn't really in the cards
and so you had situations for example
like in Helmand where general McChrystal
sent government in a box and what ended
up happening as general McChrystal later
said is that you've got a bleeding ulcer
in that country so these efforts at
trying to nation-build are often
unnecessary for America's core security
interests and really impossible to
realize in any kind of short run and at
a cost that we really think is is
appropriate given what we need to
achieve as opposed to what might be
ideal and so we've really opened up all
kinds of challenges in this attempt to
create an exemplar for the Middle East
we actually have created an exemplar an
exemplar of what could go wrong if you
engage in the world without first
thinking carefully
about what is necessary for American
safety and what those unintended
consequences of our behavior could be
and how that spills back over into the
United States in terms of the effects on
Americans the effects on our system of
government and our civil liberties and
really thinking about those human costs
because often times we forget that there
is a real price to be paid so for
example when the United States has
intervened in places like Iraq and Libya
there has been a huge human cost with
thousands of American lives lost tens of
thousands of Americans harmed by that
conflict and a real human cost at home
on families and communities not to
mention the cost to those were
ostensibly trying to help in places like
Libya and Iraq and so there are lots of
unintended consequences of not following
a more Prudential or realistic approach
to the world and what restraint tries to
do or realism is to really be cautious
about that to think about second-order
consequences to think about the human
and financial costs and to put that in
the calculus before you reach for the
sword or the bayonet to try to achieve
American foreign policy goals so Libya
is a classic case of a well-intentioned
policy gone awry so the argument was
that the United States needed to get
engaged as part of a responsibility to
protect when conflict emerged in eastern
Libya unfortunately for the United
States the consequences of this
well-intentioned set of policies did not
turn out the way we wanted it to and
this is a common problem in foreign
policy and something that a more
realistic approach would try to remedy
namely in Libya we had a situation where
we harmed those were ostensibly trying
to help namely Libyan society Libya is
an unstable country with rival parties
trying to control the government there's
also been the problem that terrorist
organizations have come to Libya arms
have spilled out of Libya helping
destabilize the region think about a
place like Mali that was destabilized by
the spillover effects of Libya it also
harmed our counter-proliferation efforts
if you're Kim Jong moon in North Korea
and you see what happened to a state
like Libya that stopped
engaging in a nuclear weapons program
and that was working with the West in
terms of counter proliferation then you
you it's no wonder that other states
might be weary of giving up these
programs or cooperating with the United
States and the international
institutions that are trying to prevent
nuclear proliferation look what happened
to Muammar Qaddafi the leader of Libya
he was eventually killed the regime was
toppled and so there was a very clear
lesson that was learned by the rest of
the world when you saw that not to
mention if you pivot over to Iraq where
you saw a country like Iraq where the
United States also engaged in regime
change so even if these attempts at
regime change were well intentioned the
results have not been positive for
America's security and safety instead
it's actually harmed stability in these
parts of the world
thus harming American interests
[Music]